Lucia:  是只把一楼的客厅装饰一下还是二楼的客厅
Jake: 就一楼吧
Jake: 然后还有各位的房间
Jake: And then everyone's rooms too.
Jake: 我可能找个时间
Jake: I'll find some time...
Jake: 今天或者明天或者等你们收拾好
Jake: Either today or tomorrow or when you guys are done.
Jake: 总之就是
Jake: Anyway...
Jake: 这几天我会把整个房子用iPhone扫一遍
Jake: I'll scan the whole house with the iPhone in the next few days.
Jake: 嗯然后各位的卧室就收拾收拾
Jake: Yeah, and you guys can tidy up your bedrooms.
Jake: 对要扫进去
Jake: Yeah, need to scan them.
Lucia: 那你要不扫之前通知一声
Lucia: How about you let us know before you scan?
Lucia: 对这样我就可以在扫之前
Lucia: So I can move the boxes before you scan.
Lucia: 把那个箱子拉起来
Lucia: I can move that box out of the way.
Tasha: 微微
Tasha: Hey, Tasha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Tasha: 你困啊
Tasha: Are you sleepy?
Katrina:  我还不困
Katrina: I'm not sleepy yet.
Katrina:  我这没口袋这个东西
Katrina: I don't have pockets for this thing.
Alice:按这个看时间长了就困了
Lucia: 要不然把它拔了
Lucia: How about just unplugging it?
Lucia: 哈哈呃你看一下它有多少电
Lucia: Haha, um, check how much battery it has left.
Jake: 如果电很多的话没关系哦
Jake: If it has a lot of battery, it's fine.
Lucia: 我在手机上能看
Lucia: I can check on my phone.
Lucia: 到它有多少电对
Lucia: I can see how much battery it has.
Alice: 哦
Alice: Oh.
Katrina:  嗯又找到他在这
Katrina: Yeah, found it here again.
Lucia: 93%也是不是应该可以吧
Jake: 可以OK
Jake: Yeah, it's okay.
Jake: 对你坐着的时候冲嘛
Jake: Yeah, charge it while you're sitting.
Jake: 然后站着就还剩这些最后这
Jake: And when you're standing, it's just the last bit.
Tasha: 就还剩这些最后这
Tasha: 最后一二三四五六六块没有
Tasha: The last one, two, three, four, five, six, six pieces left.
Tasha: 找着家了
Tasha: Found their home.
Alice:他俩像不像
Tasha: 嗯像
Tasha: 但不一定他们俩在一起感觉
Tasha: But it doesn't necessarily feel like they are together.
Tasha: 这个在这边
Tasha: This one goes here.
Shure:  他怎么突然变成network error了
Jake: 好我看一下
Jake: Okay, let me take a look.
Jake: 可以给我看一下吗
Jake: Can I see it?
Jake: 就是在我把电拔掉之后
Jake: After I unplugged it...
Lucia: 他突然变成这个界面了
Lucia: It suddenly turned into this interface.
Lucia: 是哎对这样
Lucia: Yeah, like this.
Shure:  你先把这几个字这个什么意思对齐
Shure: First align these words, what does this mean?
Jake: 重开一下
Jake: Restart it.
Jake: 我也没见过这个
Lucia: 就我把它这样
Lucia: 就是这样关掉
Lucia: Just turn it off like this.
Shure:  先先先来这个先先把一根给一边
Shure: First, first, first, give one to the side.
Shure:  给那什么好
Shure: Give it to whatever is better.
Jake: 我这出不来
Jake: I can't get this out.
Shure:  你把那缩一下
Shure: Shrink that part.
Tasha: 这样这个猪就塞不下他
Tasha: This way, the pig won't fit.
Jake: 这个长度是对的吗
Jake: Is this the right length?
Jake: 都一样的
Jake: They're all the same.
Shure:  都是一样
Shure: They're all the same.
Katrina:  对
Lucia: 啊出来了他应该还是正常的吧
Lucia: Ah, it's out, it should be normal now, right?
Lucia: 对可能是刚才有什么bug了
Jake: 或者装饰二楼
Jake: Or decorate the second floor.
Jake: 因为二楼的那个场地
Jake: Because the venue on the second floor...
Jake: 就做PPT比较方便
Jake: It's more convenient for making PPTs.
Jake: 就是就可以摆那个
Jake: We can set up...
Jake: 摆摆椅子
Jake: Set up chairs.
Jake: 摆很多椅子
Jake: Set up a lot of chairs.
Jake: 哦对对
Jake: Oh, right, right.
Lucia: 因为二楼的桌子椅子太像那个椅子了
Lucia: Because the tables and chairs on the second floor look too much like those chairs.
Alice: 对所以在二楼装饰
Alice: Yeah, so decorate the second floor.
Tasha: 他们这家该放哪里呢
Tasha: Where should they put this?
Shure:  是让毛血刷的
Shure: It's to let Mao Xue brush it.
Shure:  哈哈但我觉得他俩又不像一家
Shure: Haha, but I think they don't look like a family.
Alice: 因为这个角不太好拼
Alice: Because this corner is hard to fit.
Alice: 就比较尖的角
Alice: It's a pretty sharp corner.
Alice: 有没有比较尖的角
Alice: Are there any sharper corners?
Tasha: 他的嘴是吗
Tasha: His mouth, right?
Tasha: 哈哈剩了一圈了
Tasha: Haha, there's a whole circle left.
Jake: 这一圈很强
Jake: This circle is pretty strong.
Lucia: 但是感觉只有
Lucia: But it feels like only...
Lucia: 只有这几个是比较确定的
Lucia: Only these few are pretty certain.
Lucia: 我们找到了很多两个
Lucia: We found a lot of pairs.
Lucia: 两个是一起的
Lucia: The pairs go together.
Lucia: 但是确定了放在哪里
Lucia: But we aren't sure where to place them.
Lucia: 当然找不到他们的家
Lucia: Of course, we can't find their home.
Jake: 好多好朋友
Jake: So many good friends.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun.
Lucia: 哇哎这个真的好一致啊
Lucia: Wow, this really matches well.
Lucia: 哎我去这个
Lucia: Oh my, this...
Katrina:  你是怎么找到的
Katrina: How did you find it?
Tasha: 他这有两个尖尖
Tasha: He has two sharp points here.
Tasha: 我去这尖尖你能看到
Tasha: Oh wow, you can see these points?
Jake: 眼神真好
Jake: Your eyesight is really good.
Jake: 我这看不清
Jake: I can't see clearly from here.
Tasha: 哦这个弧度我之前看到过
Tasha: Oh, I've seen this curve before.
Jake: 有点6
Jake: That's impressive.
Shure:  人生的最后7天
Shure: The last 7 days of life.
Shure:  来吧立起来
Shure: Come on, stand it up.
Lucia: 会不会是那个鸟翅膀
Lucia: Could it be that bird wing?
Shure:  哦还有一个是吗
Shure: Oh, there's another one, right?
Shure:  对还有一个
Shure: Yes, there's another one.
Shure:  还有这个人
Shure: And this person.
Shure:  给完美
Shure: Perfect.
Katrina:  哎棒棒棒棒
Katrina: Wow, awesome, awesome, awesome.
Tasha: 那说明鸟不在边边
Tasha: That means the bird isn't on the edge.
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Hmm, yeah.
Tasha: 这个这个
Tasha: This, this...
Tasha: 感觉这个弧度很
Tasha: Feels like this curve is very...
Tasha: 像
Tasha: Similar.
Tasha: 不像哎
Tasha: No, not really.
Jake: 确实有点像
Jake: It does look a bit similar.
Lucia: 哎对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Lucia: 这个也是对的
Lucia: This one is correct too.
Jake: 这是你记住的吗嗯
Jake: Did you remember this? Hmm?
Tasha: 然后
Tasha: And then...
Katrina:  再
Katrina: Again...
Tasha: 拿
Tasha: Here.
Alice: 一个是吧
Alice: Is it just one?
Lucia: 我们刚才是不是给这个蛇
Lucia: Did we just give this snake...
Lucia: 已经找到了一个小伙伴
Lucia: ...a new friend?
Lucia: 对蛇跟那个熊猫哎
Lucia: Yeah, the snake and the panda, right?
Tasha: 怎么怎么怎么弄来着
Tasha: How did we do it again?
Lucia: 啊对对对
Lucia: Oh right, right.
Alice: 有人长这样吗
Alice: Does anyone look like this?
Lucia: 好像不太有人长这样
Lucia: It seems like no one looks like that.
Jake: 把它弄一边长是吧
Jake: Make it longer, right?
Jake: 对那把它竖过来倒过来
Jake: Yeah, turn it vertically and upside down.
Tasha: 就还剩最后的
Tasha: Only the last one left.
Tasha: 这这两个也没找着家是吗对
Tasha: These two haven't found a home yet, right?
Tasha: 还剩最后5个没找着家的
Tasha: 要不尝试着把它们把这些放进去吧
Tasha: How about we try putting these in?
Jake: 这些形状就出来了
Jake: These shapes are coming out.
Shure:  都行其实嗯
Shure: Anything works, actually.
Shure:  也别太长
Shure: Don't make it too long.
Shure:  别比那个黑板
Shure: Don't make it longer than the blackboard.
Lucia: 这怎么放能让他不不位移这样呗
Lucia: How can we place it so it doesn't move?
Shure:  这个还是高嗯
Shure: This one is still high, hmm.
Jake: 这个高一点
Jake: This one is a bit higher.
Shure:  再高一点点这个
Shure: A little bit higher, this one.
Shure:  啊过了
Shure: Ah, it's over.
Shure:  过了过了
Shure: It's over, over.
Jake: OK OK好
Jake: OK, OK, good.
Tasha: 好像不太像算了
Shure:  把它拼上对
Shure: Put it together, right.
Shure:  good good good
Shure: Good, good, good.
Alice: 这俩像在一块吗
Alice: Do these two seem like they go together?
Shure:  人类的智慧
Shure: Human wisdom.
Tasha: 像又不太像
Tasha: They seem like they do, but not quite.
Lucia: 这个好像
Lucia: This one seems like it.
Lucia: 是不是很像在一起啊
Lucia: Doesn't it look like they're together?
Lucia: 这俩嗯
Lucia: These two, hmm.
Lucia: 然后这个如果还在这的话就是这样
Lucia: And if this one is still here, it's like this.
Shure:  师傅你是干什么工作的
Shure: Master, what do you do for a living?
Jake: 修空调了
Jake: I repair air conditioners.
Lucia: 接下来这里还缺一口
Lucia: Next, there's still a gap here.
Shure:  先头先头按上去
Shure: Attach the head first.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Jake: 这个我就一个吗
Jake: Do I only have one of these?
Jake: 很短是谁呢
Jake: Who is the short one?
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  OK的OK
Shure: It's okay, it's okay.
Shure:  我们已经越来越剧情真相了
Shure: We're getting more and more into the storyline.
Tasha: 对哈哈
Tasha: Yeah, haha.
Tasha: 越来越有拼下去的动力了
Tasha: Getting more motivated to continue.
Tasha: 还有3个人无家可归
Katrina: 哎不是他
Tasha: 这个感觉这个小家伙在哪都行
Tasha: This little guy seems to be okay anywhere.
Tasha: 所以他好像不能放在里面
Tasha: So he probably can't stay inside.
Jake: 哎呀
Jake: Oh no.
Jake: 纯手工
Jake: Handmade.
Lucia: 这如果有一个戳尖角的地方
Lucia: If there's a sharp corner here,
Lucia: 应该挺好的才对啊
Lucia: It should be pretty good.
Shure:  跟下面它是个六六边形的
Shure: It's a hexagon at the bottom.
Alice:超过盘了哦
Alice: It's over the limit.
Jake: 不行
Jake: That's not okay.
Lucia: 啊，对不起
Lucia: Ah, sorry.
Shure:  对卡死
Shure: Yeah, it's stuck.
Shure:  你先把那个螺母推进去
Shure: Push the nut in first.
Shure:  然后上面就可以进行下一步
Katrina:  看他只有一个
Katrina: He only has one.
Katrina:  这个是吗
Katrina: Is this it?
Lucia: 这个猫好像不在这里
Lucia: This cat doesn't seem to be here.
Jake: 但是你可以把右边形给找着
Jake: But you can find the right shape on the right.
Lucia: 这造型会是什么呢
Lucia: What will this shape be?
Jake: 哎呀哎呀哎呀这啥呀
Jake: Oh my, what's this?
Lucia: 这个吗
Jake: 吓我一跳
Jake: Scared me.
Shure:  完了你给你给人家伙试试
Shure: Try it, give it a shot.
Shure:  给人饭碗
Shure:  完了
Shure: Done.
Lucia: 那好像又不是真想要完全放进去
Lucia: It seems like it doesn't fully fit in.
Tasha: 可是就是会有点肉
Tasha: But it will have some edges.
Jake: 感觉有点甜品
Jake: It feels like there's some dessert
Lucia: 甜品
Lucia: Dessert
Tasha: 这个是在这的吧
Tasha: This is here, right?
Lucia: 哎是是是
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes
Tasha: 嘿嘿嘿
Tasha: Haha
Lucia: 那这个应该就不在
Lucia: Then this shouldn't be here
Tasha:  我感觉这个不对了
Tasha: 对这个不对
Tasha: Yeah, this is wrong
Lucia: 塞进去了
Lucia: It's stuffed in
Lucia: 不对那这个肯定在这
Lucia: No, then this must be here
Lucia: 这个真的
Lucia: This really
Lucia: 怎么看都有点像一个猫
Lucia: Looks kind of like a cat
Lucia: 或者之类的东西
Lucia: Or something like that
Tasha: 弄不清
Alice:这个头吗
Alice: This head?
Alice: 这不是
Tasha: 嗯这是松
Tasha: Hmm, this is loose
Jake: 可以这是荒野去排练
Tasha: Okay, this is to rehearse in the wild
Lucia: 无限尝试
Lucia: Infinite attempts
Tasha: 刚刚这个
Tasha:  刚刚这个是归谁吗
Alice:这个不归谁
Katrina: 啊行
Katrina: Ah, okay
Shure: 完了
Shure: Done
Alice: 哎对啊
Alice: Oh, yeah
Alice: 他们仨是归着的呀
Alice: They are grouped together
Tasha:他们仨是归着的
Katrina:  然后这还有一组这还有一组
Katrina: And there's another group here, another group here
Jake: 所以这个是干嘛的呀
Jake: So what is this for?
Alice: 这个这个有归家吗
Alice: Does this have a home?
Lucia: 斯他刚才咱是不是他和熊猫也是女生
Lucia: Earlier, wasn't he and the panda also girls?
Lucia: 他是加黑板
Lucia: He added the blackboard.
Lucia: 不是他是蛇是蛇
Lucia: No, he's a snake.
Lucia: 那这个豹子
Lucia: Then this leopard...
Shure: 他俩应该不是不穿一起
Shure: They shouldn't wear together.
Lucia: 这豹子这个平平的面很好找呀
Lucia: This leopard, this flat face is easy to find.
Shure:  看图
Shure: Look at the picture.
Katrina:  这里哦这里有六边形
Katrina: Here, oh, there is a hexagon here.
Jake: 卡住了嗯
Jake: It's stuck, hmm.
Jake: 不是这卡住的了
Jake: No, this is stuck.
Lucia: 有没有可能豹子
Lucia: Could it be the leopard?
Lucia: 在别的什么地方
Lucia: In some other place?
Jake: 不对
Jake: No.
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: No.
Katrina: 这俩人
Katrina: These two people.
Katrina:  干啥
Katrina: What are they doing?
Alice:这里这样子的
Alice: Here like this.
Lucia: 哎可以可以对
Tasha: OK
Jake: 我到那边试
Jake: I'll try over there.
Tasha: 只剩最后两个人
Tasha: Only two people left.
Tasha: 没有家可以跪了
Tasha: No home to return to.
Tasha: 没有家可以归了
Tasha: 然后我们就可以放到左边
Tasha: Then we can place it on the left.
Lucia: 他们有没有可能也是在边上的
Lucia: Could they also be on the side?
Lucia: 这一圈看着还挺像一个弧度的
Lucia: This whole circle looks like an arc.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 那这还直
Tasha: Then this is still straight.
Jake: 这正好还差他一个边
Jake: This just needs one more side.
Alice: 对其中那个平平的是不是这个
Alice: Right, is the flat one this?
Alice: 这可能不在那边
Alice: This might not be on that side.
Jake: 哦那那个应该是卡在这了
Jake: Oh, then that one should be stuck here.
Lucia: 这个可能他是一个边
Lucia: This might be one side.
Jake: 看起来是吗
Jake: Does it look like that?
Lucia: 跑了
Lucia: It ran away.
Jake: 他是卡在这了
Jake: It's stuck here.
Lucia: 然后这个在这
Lucia: And this one is here.
Lucia: 他们应该怎么确定
Lucia: How should they confirm it?
Lucia: 有点像边
Lucia: Kind of like a side.
Shure: 我想想看
Shure: Let me think.
Jake: 我还要看一眼
Jake: I need to take another look.
Lucia: 对他们有点像是一个边
Lucia: Yeah, they kind of look like one side.
Lucia: 嗯好
Lucia: Hmm, okay.
Lucia: 虽然不是100%确定
Lucia: Although I'm not 100% sure.
Lucia: 有可能时这样的吗
Tasha: 哎他们俩正好就这样子了
Tasha: Hey, they just happened to be like this.
Tasha: 嗯OK了
Tasha: Hmm, OK.
Tasha: 本来他们俩还分开了
Tasha: They were separated before.
Jake: 比划比划要不
Jake: How about we compare them?
Lucia: 哦原来这个牛
Lucia: Oh, so this is cool.
Lucia: 底下这里是配它的
Lucia: This bottom part is k-tazza.
Lucia: 我就说这个地方应该很好
Lucia: I was saying this part should be good.
Tasha: 刚刚找了半天
Tasha: We've been looking for a long time.
Tasha:居然正好就找进去了
Lucia: 歪打正着
Lucia: Lucky hit.
Tasha: 现在感觉把边整理整理
Tasha: Now it feels like the edges are organized.
Tasha: 然后再把这几个组进去就行了
Tasha: Then we just need to put these groups in.
Tasha:ok
Jake: 这个是
Jake: This is...
Jake: 放哪呢
Lucia: 这些个编的顺序拼的
Lucia: These sequences of editing...
Lucia: 不一定是
Lucia: Might not be...
Shure: 对的
Tasha:  对
Katrina: 它是怎么卡出黑板的
Shure:  是我在想他怎么卡的
Shure: I'm wondering how he got stuck.
Shure:  躺下来的
Shure: Lying down.
Shure:  底下得有一个接着他的地方
Shure: There has to be something supporting him underneath.
Tasha: 这个借我用一下
Tasha: 是不是这样子
Tasha: Is it like this?
Alice: 你觉得这个像不像边
Alice: Do you think this looks like an edge?
Jake: 这个会有卡的吗
Jake: Will this get stuck?
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one.
Lucia: 也有一点
Lucia: It also has a bit.
Lucia: 放进去试试
Lucia: Try putting it in.
Tasha: 我刚把哪个取出来来着
Tasha: Which one did I just take out?
Alice: 就这样是不像一个边
Alice: Doesn't this look like an edge?
Alice: 哎对
Alice: Yeah, right.
Alice: 也像一个边
Alice: It also looks like an edge.
Lucia: 那这里需要卡吗
Lucia: Does this part need to be stuck?
Alice: 哎这个吗
Alice: This one?
Shure:  这是卡这哦
Shure: This part here.
Lucia: 有可能把他推过来
Lucia: Maybe push it over.
Alice: 哎拼上了哦
Alice: It fits together!
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, amazing.
Lucia: 我刚找到了
Lucia: I just found it.
Shure:  哎智慧
Shure: Oh, wisdom.
Jake: 智慧
Jake: Wisdom.
Tasha: 放哪了
Tasha: Where did you put it?
Jake: 哎
Jake: Huh?
Tasha: 我刚刚这样
Katrina: 接近真相了啊这
Tasha: 这3个都是怎么拼来着
Shure:  牛逼
Shure: Awesome.
Jake: 确实牛逼
Jake: Definitely awesome.
Tasha: 啊对
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 就这样啊
Tasha: Just like that.
Shure:  下面那个
Shure: The one below.
Shure:  对然后哇
Shure: Yeah, and wow.
Katrina:  然后下面很正规
Katrina: And then the bottom part is very formal.
Tasha: 像像挨着这个的
Shure:  必然
Tasha: Definitely feels like it.
Tasha: 就这个地方
Tasha: Right here at this spot.
Jake: 是不没这么长
Jake: Isn't it not this long?
Jake: 那把这个加低一点
Jake: Then lower this a bit.
Lucia: 挨着这里挨着这里
Lucia: Next to here, next to here.
Lucia: 呃，推一下这里
Lucia: Uh, push this part.
Alice:他俩拼到了
Alice: They matched it.
Lucia: 他俩拼到了
Lucia: They matched it.
Lucia: 哎呀，刚刚那个呢
Lucia: Oh no, what about the earlier one?
Tasha: 好好好真相只有一个
Tasha: Okay, okay, there's only one truth.
Lucia: 啊，我，我
Lucia: Ah, I, I...
Jake:可以
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 什么
Lucia: 再往好像再往这里推一点点
Lucia: Push it a bit more in this direction.
Lucia: 就是往这个方向推一点点
Lucia: Just push it a bit more this way.
Lucia: 哎再往上往下
Lucia: Uh, a bit up, a bit down.
Jake: 就是往下
Jake: Just down.
Jake: 下不来对
Jake: Can't come down, right.
Lucia: 这好像还挺像的
Lucia: This looks quite similar.
Lucia: 嗯好
Lucia: Hmm, okay.
Lucia: 有可能是动
Lucia: Maybe it moved.
Shure:  太牛了我们
Shure: We are so awesome.
Lucia: 接下来的这一边
Lucia: Finished this side.
杨硕：拼好了
Jake: Finished it.
Shure:  这黑板可还行
Shure: This blackboard is quite good.
Lucia: 难道是这个吗
Jake: 确实有黑板
Jake: Indeed, there's a blackboard.
Jake: 他背面就是黑板
Jake: The back side is a blackboard.
Jake: 他俩是一
Jake: They are together.
Shure:  这是粉笔
Shure: This is chalk.
Alice:它俩是一家的
Lucia: 它俩是一家的在这里
Jake: 是的他送来几个粉笔
Jake: Yes, he sent a few pieces of chalk.
Lucia: 哦这样子的
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Jake: 这个还能凑一点
Jake: This can be pieced together a bit more.
Tasha: 他们是这样子的
Tasha: They are like this.
Tasha: 弧形
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: 有没有可能呢
Lucia: Is it possible?
Lucia: 角度好像稍微有点卡住了
Lucia: The angle seems to be a bit stuck.
Jake: 放哪了太牛了
Jake: Where did you put it? That's amazing.
Jake: 放这边了
Jake: Put it here.
Lucia: 可以有点像
Lucia: It could look a bit like it.
Lucia: 但怎么感觉好像不完全对似的
Lucia: But why does it feel like it's not entirely right?
Tasha: 因为这还有这么大块呢
Tasha: Because there's still this big piece.
Tasha: 对我感觉会这么一大块
Tasha: Yeah, I feel like it should be a big piece.
Tasha: 挪个位他们应该都这这
Lucia: 这一块这么不规则
Lucia: This piece is so irregular.
Lucia: 他应该是在中间的吧
Lucia: It should be in the middle, right?
Lucia: 嗯他会在哪
Lucia: Hmm, where would it be?
Lucia: 我把它先取出来
Lucia: I'll take it out first.
Lucia: 哎有点像那个地方啊
Lucia: Hey, it looks a bit like that spot.
Lucia: 稍等
Lucia: 好像也不是
Lucia: It seems like it's not either.
Tasha: 先把他放进去吧
Tasha: Let's put it in first.
Lucia: 哎好像可以
Tasha: 可以可以
Lucia: 对好像可以
Lucia: Yeah, it seems like it can.
Lucia: 哎但这样的话
Lucia: Hey, but if we do this,
Lucia: 这里好像又拼不上了
Lucia: It seems like we can't fit this part anymore.
Lucia: 但这两个肯定是挨着
Lucia: But these two are definitely next to each other.
Lucia: 可是没事
Lucia: But it's okay.
Alice: 这个边不一定在这
Alice: This side doesn't necessarily go here.
Alice: 把这个边先拿出来
Alice: Let's take this side out first.
Katrina:  可以可以
Katrina: It can, it can.
Lucia: 那就把那个牛和那个啥放一起
Lucia: Then let's put that cow and that thing together.
Lucia:然后这个是在
Lucia: And then this is at...
Lucia: 但这个好像是在他的上面
Lucia: But this seems to be on top of it.
Lucia: 这样子的
Lucia: Like this.
Lucia: 然后这里再有一个
Lucia: Then there's another one here.
Tasha: 这个边也不一定对对
Tasha: This side might not necessarily be right either.
Lucia: 对这个边的位置
Lucia: Yeah, this side's position.
Lucia: 等一下把这个边合开
Lucia: Wait a minute, let's put this side together.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Tasha: 可是这个边这样是对的呀
Shure: 困了
Jake:几点睡的
Katrina:  1点
Lucia: 这应该是对的
Lucia: This should be right.
Lucia: 就这这   Shure: 1点多
Lucia: Just this...
Lucia: 就这这1点
Jake: 5点醒的
Jake: Woke up at 5.
Jake: 10点睡到这都是对的
Jake: Sleeping from 10 to now is right.
Tasha: 连到这都是对的
Jake: 啊够了
Jake: Ah, that's enough.
Jake: 够你睡
Jake: Enough sleep for you.
Tasha: 只有这个边和这个边位
Tasha: Only this side and this side...
Tasha: 人类是这样的
Tasha: People are like this.
Shure:  五点半睡的
Shure: Slept at 5:30.
Lucia: 好奇怪啊
Lucia: So strange.
Shure:  七点醒
Shure: Woke up at 7, slept at 5:30.
Alice: 要不
Alice: How about...
Alice: 先把这个不确定的边先给他拿过来
Alice: First, bring that uncertain part over here.
Katrina: 你五点半才睡
Katrina:  那你才是真正的不用睡觉
Katrina: Then you really don't need sleep.
Shure:  整两杯咖啡吧
Shure: Let's make two cups of coffee.
Shure:  不然话你受不了了
Shure: Otherwise, you won't be able to handle it.
Jake: 好帮我整两杯
Jake: Okay, make me two cups.
Jake: 走我们一起整两杯
Jake: Let's go make two cups together.
Katrina:  出门吗上楼
Jake:上楼
Katrina:  哎你们有咖啡机吗
Katrina: Hey, do you have a coffee machine?
Jake: 没有没有手抓哎
Jake: No, no, it's all by hand.
Lucia:好奇怪啊
Jake: 纯纯手动
Jake: All manual.
Lucia: 嗯看看
Lucia: Hmm, let's see.
Katrina:  应该是还有两个花瓶的快递没有签收
Katrina: There should be two more vase deliveries that haven't been signed for.
Katrina:  签收的话他就
Katrina: Once signed for, then...
Jake: 下午会有人带我们去做
Jake: Someone will take us to do it in the afternoon.
Jake: 那个高尔夫球车你看到了吗
Jake: Did you see that golf cart?
Jake: 我没看到
Jake: I didn't see it.
Lucia: 有谁有脚吗
Lucia: 就是i这个突出来的这个地方
Alice:你知道咋拼来着
Tasha: 哈哈
Alice: 坏了现在脑子已经转不动了
Lucia: 是的但这个其实也还蛮像的
Lucia: Yeah, but this actually looks quite similar
Alice: 现在咋拼来着
Alice: 谁和我看过这个
Alice: Who watched this with me?
Tasha: 这个和谁是一家来着
Tasha: Who was this with?
Lucia: 这个这个这个和他们吧
Tasha: 它是和谁是一家来着
Lucia: 哎等等
Lucia: 他和这个鹰我记得在鹰翅膀的某个地方
Lucia: 可能是这这这
Lucia: Maybe this, this, this
Tasha: 啊
Lucia: 对的对的
Lucia: 然后这样子
Alice:哎这个咋拼来着
Alice:怎么一会拼着拼着拼迷了
Alice:嗯对
Lucia: 这个半圆怎办还缺一部分呢
Tasha: 天哪
Tasha: 这放哪来着
Alice:哎呀又拼迷了
Lucia: 这个半圆
Tasha: 哦哦找到了
Tasha: Oh, oh, found it.
Lucia: 找到了找到了
Lucia: Found it, found it.
Lucia: 在这里
Tasha: ok
Tasha: 哇我们仨是天才
Tasha: Wow, the three of us are geniuses.
Lucia: 然后这几个刚才怎么回事
Lucia: 这样的是吗
Tasha: 对对对
Lucia: 然后这还有一个
Tasha: 现在还少一个
Lucia:  怎么还少一块啊
Jake: Chairs together.
Lucia: 咋回事
Lucia: What's going on?
Tasha: 少少一块
Lucia: 咋回事
Alice:会不会是它
Tasha: 啊ok耶
Lucia: 耶
Alice:这要把它放进去就行了
Lucia: 胜利近在眼前
Katrina: Victory is within reach.
Lucia: 这个地方是不是在这里啊
Lucia: Is this place right here?
Lucia: 那就不不太一样
Lucia: Then it’s not quite the same.
Lucia: 不完全一样
Lucia: Not exactly the same.
Lucia: 他就那边大一些啊
Lucia: It's just a bit bigger over there.
Tasha: 啊
Lucia: 又散了
Alice:你颤音了
Tasha: 崩溃了
Tasha: I'm breaking down.
Lucia: 收集一些拼图数据可还行
Lucia: Collecting some puzzle data, how about that?
Tasha: 让AI知道
Tasha: Let the AI know.
Lucia: 快了快了
Lucia: Almost there, almost there.
Alice: 这俩咋拼一起的
Lucia: 我们现在可以整体根据这个形状
Lucia: We can look at the overall shape now.
Lucia: 来看一看
Lucia: Let's take a look.
Alice: 是不在这呀
Alice: 哇天才
Alice: Wow, genius!
Lucia: 可以可以可以
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes.
Lucia: 对的对的
Lucia: That's right.
Lucia: 来哎
Lucia: Come on.
Tasha: 放进去放进去放进去
Lucia: 那我觉得那个鹰翅膀就是在这里
Lucia: 我觉得鹰翅膀就是在这里
Lucia: I think the eagle's wings should go here.
Lucia: 稍等，我们比划比划
Lucia: Hold on, let's measure it.
Tasha: 如果鹰翅膀放在这里的话哎
Tasha: If the eagle's wings go here...
Tasha: 屁股就撅在这是吧
Tasha: The tail will stick out here, right?
Lucia: 对这屁股应该是在这个地方吧
Lucia: Yeah, the tail should be in this spot.
Alice:啊对对对
Tasha: 屁股撅在这
Lucia: 然后鹰翅放在这啊
Lucia: Then the wings go here.
Alice: 蛇啊这蛇在这呢
Tasha: 哦
Lucia: 哇太不容易了
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: 然后这个这个松鼠
Lucia: 好像是在是在鹰翅膀这里
Lucia: 哈哈哈不行
Lucia: Haha, no way.
Alice: 这个要最后放
Alice: This should be placed last.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Lucia: 因为他哪都可以
Tasha: 喊他们
Alice: 我们见证奇迹的时刻
Alice: The moment of witnessing a miracle.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈太难了
Alice: Hahaha, it's so hard.
Alice: 来我们录一下这个数据
Alice: Let's record this data.
Alice: 好你来
Alice: Okay, come over here.
Jake: 咖啡味已经出来了呢
Jake: The coffee aroma is already coming out.
Lucia:  快快快这可是人类早期
Jake: Hurry, hurry, this is from early human times.
Lucia: 好不容易拼出拼图的珍贵数据
Lucia: It's hard to piece together such precious data.
Alice:快来快来
Lucia: 哈哈
Jake:来了来了来了来了来了
Jake: 拼好了哈哈哈
Jake: It's done, haha.
Jake: 哦哈哈
Jake: Oh, haha.
Jake: 好强啊
Alice:累死了
Lucia: 太不容易了哇靠
Jake:哇靠
Jake: 太强了
Jake: So strong.
Jake: 用了多久
Jake: How long did it take?
Alice: 不知道
Lucia: 多久
Jake: 应该半个多小时
Jake: Probably more than half an hour.
Katrina:  所以土地公公在哪
Katrina: So where is the Earth God?
Lucia: 哪个土地公公这啊
Lucia: Which Earth God, this one?
Lucia: 他就在边上哈哈
Lucia: He's right next to it, haha.
Jake: 这个到时候秀给客人
Jake: We'll show this to the guests later.
Jake: 这个还有点脸面
Jake: This has a bit of face value.
Jake: 哼这我们拼好了
Jake: Hmph, we completed this.
Jake: 然后你们再来拼
Jake: Then you guys can try.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 他上面是不是还有
Lucia: Is there more on top?
Lucia: 一个一个榫就这样子卡住了
Lucia: 应该就这脸啊
Lucia: It should be just this face.
Alice: 啊，那
Alice: Ah, then...
Jake:这个也可以研究一会
Jake: This can be studied for a while.
Jake: 那这个是不是可以那
Jake: So can this be...
Tasha: 再互相卡一点
Lucia: 哎呦哎呦小心小心别洒了
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈放平吧要不行好了啊
Lucia: Haha, lay it flat, otherwise it's done, okay?
Jake:放平吧要不行
Lucia: 对然后就这样子夹住
Lucia: Yeah, then just clamp it like this.
Jake:这就合理多了
Katrina:  稳定的三角形结构
Katrina: A stable triangular structure.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 为了防止它散还可以就先装进来
Lucia: To prevent it from falling apart, we can put it in here first.
Lucia: 这样挡一下感觉
Lucia: Block it like this, it feels more secure.
Lucia: 对这样就不容易块就不容易掉出来
Lucia: Yeah, this way it's less likely to fall apart.
Jake: 挺好的
Jake: Pretty good.
Lucia: 哎把这一边朝着另外那一边
Lucia: Align this side with the other side.
Alice: 好呀哈哈
Alice: Okay, haha.
Lucia: 小心哈哈
Lucia: Be careful, haha.
Alice: 土地公掉了不该冒这个险
Alice: The Earth God fell, we shouldn't take this risk.
Alice: 好的这次我不冒险
Alice: Alright, I won't take any risks this time.
Lucia: 哎这个拼好蛮好看的
Lucia: This piece looks quite nice when assembled.
Lucia: 就不知为何
Lucia: Just don't know why.
Lucia: 有种日本服饰会的那种画风的感觉
Lucia: It has a vibe similar to Japanese clothing style.
Lucia: 啊哈哈
Lucia: Ah, haha.
Alice:这样头挤着屁股的这种
Lucia: 耶
Alice: 和谐相处
Alice: Living in harmony.
Jake:看一看有多和谐
Alice: 和谐吗和谐
Alice: Harmonious? Yes, harmonious.
Lucia: 就在我们的这个地球上
Lucia: Just on our Earth.
Lucia: 和谐共处哦
Lucia: Coexisting in harmony.
Jake: 就熊猫后面他很开心的感觉
Jake: The panda at the back looks really happy.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈这个表情
Jake: Haha, that expression.
Jake: 嚯你们拼的是真不容易
Jake: Wow, you guys really worked hard on this.
Jake: 哈哈哈是吗
Jake: Haha, right?
Lucia:  哈哈哈是吗
Jake: 看得出来看得出来
Jake: I can tell, I can tell.
Lucia: 尝试了好长时间
Lucia: Tried for a long time.
Lucia: 因为他每个边
Jake:就是这一些
Jake: 这一些你们怎么拼起来的呀
Jake: How did you piece them together?
Jake: 这个地方
Jake: This part.
Alice: 就是找那种你看像这种比较紧密的
Alice: 哦哦就先拼起来
Alice: Oh, oh, just piece them first.
Alice: 然后大块大块大块的看
Alice: Then look at the bigger pieces.
Alice: 最后大块怎么拼起来
Alice: Finally piece the big ones together.
Jake: 对我看上面的可能还好一点
Jake: Yeah, the top part might be a bit easier.
Tasha: 对就这种就找到找到边缘
Tasha: Yeah, just find the edges like this.
Jake:这边很难
Alice:对对对就是差不多最后拼起来
Jake: 这个边缘确实还挺圆的
Jake: This edge is pretty round.
Lucia: 嗯除了这一块但是后面就是这
Lucia: Yeah, except for this part, but then...
Lucia: 这部分拼好之后
Lucia: After we put this part together...
Lucia: 我们就发现他这个弧度很像是这个圆
Lucia: We found that this curve looks a lot like this circle.
Lucia: 所以就还是放在边上
Lucia: So we still put it on the side.
Alice:哦你看一下
Alice: 一开始这个就不在这个弧的考虑范围
Alice: At the beginning, this wasn't considered part of the curve.
Lucia: 对嗯对障眼法
Lucia: Yeah, right, an optical illusion.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Impressive.
Jake: 旅游啊
Jake: Tourist spot.
Alice: 累死的路啊
Alice: An exhausting road.
Lucia: 好有成就感啊
Lucia: Feels so accomplished.
Tasha:  哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 我不敢想象
Tasha: I can't imagine.
Tasha: 如果后面客人来玩这
Tasha: If guests come to play later...
Tasha: 玩一个小时会不会想走
Tasha: After an hour, they might want to leave.
Tasha: 哈哈哈客人可能拼一拼就
Tasha: Hahaha, the guests might just...
Lucia: 哎呀不拼了我们要下一个节目哈哈
Lucia: Oh, forget it, we want to move on to the next show, haha.
Jake: 我们琢磨琢磨
Jake: Let's think about it.
Jake: 这个要要不看看你的开箱
Jake: How about we take a look at your unboxing?
Tasha: 我的开箱啊
Tasha: My unboxing?
Tasha: 我
Tasha: I...
Jake:你有好的东西要不给我们秀一秀
Jake: You have good stuff, why don't you show us?
Lucia: 哎我的刚才
Lucia: Hey, my...
Lucia: 哦在这
Tasha: 不用吧
Jake: 不用秀蛋糕的模具
Jake: No need to show the cake molds.
Tasha: 4寸和6寸的
Tasha: 4-inch and 6-inch.
Tasha: 裱花嘴
Tasha: Piping tips.
Katrina:  打蛋器打蛋器搅拌棒
Katrina: Whisk, whisk, mixing stick.
Jake: 太专业了
Jake: So professional.
Tasha: 裱花嘴
Tasha: Piping tips.
Tasha: 薄脆
Tasha: Crisp.
Tasha: 刮板
Tasha: Scraper.
Jake: 这什么呀
Jake: What's this?
Alice:刮板
Tasha: 刮板
Jake: 哦哦哦
Tasha: 啊也可以平的也可以切面团
Tasha: Ah, you can flatten it or cut the dough.
Tasha: 明白明白
Tasha: Got it, got it.
Tasha: 这个想的是做
Tasha: This is meant for...
Alice: 杯子的那种对
Alice: For the cups, right?
Lucia: 纸杯甜点那种吗
Lucia: You mean the cupcake ones?
Alice:饮料应该也行
Jake: 30306090120是吧一盒30 卖的话是吗
Jake: 30, 60, 90, 120, right? A box of 30. Is that for selling?
Jake: 定价多少钱
Tasha: 对
Tasha: 定价啊定价一般1515
Tasha: The price, hmm, usually 15, 15.
Tasha: 15 这个是送的哦
Tasha: 15. This one is a freebie, though.
Tasha: 吉利丁粉
Tasha: Gelatin powder.
Katrina:  啊凝固用的
Katrina: Ah, for solidifying.
Tasha: 鸟嘴量杯
Shure:  咱们纸抽在哪
Tasha: Where are the tissue boxes?
Jake: 呃这边怎么了
Shure:  摆摆桌子上的我刚刚找纸抽呢忘了
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Tasha: 糖粉
Alice: 哎我们的拼图呢
Alice: Hey, where's our puzzle?
Katrina:  在这里
Katrina: Right here.
Jake: 哎呀幸好外面有一层对
Jake: Oh, luckily it has an outer layer.
Alice: 来欣赏
Alice: Come, admire it.
Jake: 摇起来
Jake: Shake it.
Alice: 电子秤
Alice: Digital scale.
Tasha: 还有的袋子呢
Tasha: Where are the other bags?
Jake: 这边有很多
Jake: There are plenty here.
Jake: 是这个吗
Jake: Is it this one?
Tasha: 呃这些对吧
Tasha: Uh, these ones, right?
Tasha: 用
Tasha: Use them.
Tasha: 纸杯
Tasha: Paper cups.
Tasha: 呃量温度的
Tasha: Uh, to measure the temperature.
Jake: 烤箱在哪
Jake: Where's the oven?
Tasha: 打蛋器那呢
Jake: And the mixer?
Jake: 那我们放哪呢
Jake: Where should we put them?
Jake: 我放哪比较合适
Jake: Where's the best place to put them?
Katrina: 削皮刀
Tasha: 放这呗这我觉得应该放烤箱上面
Jake: Put it here, I think it should go on top of the oven.
Tasha: 呃微波炉上面会比较合适
Tasha: Um, it might be better on top of the microwave.
Shure:  咱这边只有微波炉
Shure: We only have a microwave here.
Jake: 你买烤箱了
Jake: Did you buy an oven?
Tasha:  温度计烤箱温度计
Alice:黑巧吗
Tasha: 对黑巧做那种熔浆蛋糕
Tasha: Yes, dark chocolate for molten lava cakes.
Katrina:  好专业
Alice:啊这提拉米苏那个
Alice: 对对对提拉米苏的铲
Tasha: 还有提拉米苏的盒子哪呢
Tasha: And where's the tiramisu box?
Tasha: 嗯这伯爵红茶包这些东
Tasha: Hmm, these Earl Grey tea bags...
Jake: 西昨天应该都扫一遍
Jake: Should've scanned everything yesterday.
Tasha: 可可粉
Jake: 扫一天
Jake: Scan for a day.
Tasha: 这个是那个咖啡酒
Tasha: This is the coffee liqueur.
Tasha: 咖啡酒就是帮忙
Tasha: Coffee liqueur is just for help.
Katrina: 你会调酒吗
Jake: Do you know how to mix drinks?
Shure:  我啊嗯
Shure: Me? Uh, yeah.
Jake: 看起来可以会
Tasha: 三个模具
Lucia: 最最简单的
Lucia: The simplest way.
Lucia: 买一瓶威士忌
Lucia: Buy a bottle of whiskey.
Lucia: 买买几瓶可乐
Lucia: And a few bottles of cola.
Lucia: 然后兑一块就完事了
Lucia: Then just mix them together.
Katrina:  咱有多少个杯子呀
Katrina: How many cups do we have?
Katrina:  有20个杯
Katrina: We have 20 cups.
Shure:  有上面6个下面6个12个
Lucia:  哎小心
Jake: 我靠这什么
Jake: What the heck is this?
Jake: 架上去吧
Jake: Put it up there.
Shure:  咱们经费这么充足吗
Shure: Do we have that much budget?
Shure:  我感觉我是不是应该花花呀
Shure: Should I be spending it?
Katrina: 哈哈咱都是他的助手
Jake: 对这边主要花了
Jake: Yeah, we mainly spent money on this.
Jake: 花了很有用的很多费用
Jake: We spent a lot on very useful things.
Katrina: 买点柠檬片
Jake:非常有用
Katrina:  我来记一下
Katrina: I'll note it down.
Lucia: 啊对我也要买柠檬
Lucia: Ah yes, I need to buy lemons too.
Jake:嗯对下午要买东西就记一下菜单吧
Tasha: Hmm, yeah, let's note down what we need to buy this afternoon.
Jake: 或者单写写在这个白板上面
Jake: Or you can write it on this whiteboard.
Jake: 这个白板现在你们都可以写吧
Jake: You all can write on this whiteboard now, right?
Jake: 比较好写
Jake: It's easier to write.
Shure:  这白板拍一下拍
Shure: Take a picture of the whiteboard.
Jake: 拍完了然后擦
Jake: After taking the picture, erase it.
Jake: 再拍一下擦掉吧
Jake: Take another picture after erasing it.
Shure:  我刚拍了还有
Shure: I just took one, there's still more.
Tasha: 这里还有
Jake: 都可以调监控的
Jake: You can check the surveillance too.
Katrina:  提拉米苏
Lucia: 哦那个手指饼干
Lucia: Oh, those ladyfingers.
Lucia: 嗯对就这么拍你
Lucia: Yeah, just take it like that.
Jake: 淀粉肉松
Jake: Starch and meat floss.
Shure:  哈哈哈哇真的好赛博呀
Shure: Hahaha, wow, it's really cyber.
Tasha: 可可豆
Shure:  看一眼我拍完你的
Shure: Look at what I took of you.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Jake:我记住你了
Tasha: 那个抹茶粉
Tasha: 但这家特别贵
Tasha: But this place is really expensive.
Tasha: 还好经费充足
Tasha: Luckily, we have enough budget.
Katrina:  哇你看看啊
Katrina: Wow, look at that.
Lucia: 大手套
Katrina: 可以买点饮料
Shure:  这啥呀酒
Shure: What's that, alcohol?
Jake: 很多酒
Jake: Lots of alcohol.
Jake: 可以
Alice:沙茶酱吗
Tasha: 切蛋糕胚的
Tasha: For cutting the cake base.
Tasha: 然后还有固定器
Katrina: 这个冰袋
Lucia: 这个怎么用啊
Katrina: How do you use this?
Tasha: 就是你把这个固定器
Katrina: 这有冷冻还是有冷藏
Tasha: 比如说你不是切了一个蛋糕了吗
Tasha: For example, when you cut a cake.
Tasha: 其实也可以
Tasha: Actually, you can also.
Tasha: 然后就把这两个固定就固定在第几层
Tasha: 然后呢用这个刀这样横着过去
Tasha: Then use this knife to go across horizontally like this.
Tasha: 对然后他就会切出来很平整的面
Shure:  哎不是再往下一个
Alice: 换套吗
Tasha: 无菌手套
Tasha: Sterile gloves.
Tasha: 低筋面粉
Tasha: 黄豆粉
Tasha: Soybean flour.
Katrina:  嗯嗯养乐多
Katrina: Hmm, Yakult.
Tasha: 嗯糯米粉
Tasha: Hmm, glutinous rice flour.
Tasha: 没了哇
Tasha: It's gone.
Lucia: 好丰盛的材料
Lucia: Such abundant ingredients.
Jake: 我去
Jake: Oh my.
Lucia: 这边挪一点
Lucia: Move this a bit here.
Lucia: 这个是我的
Lucia: This one's mine.
Lucia: 我的眼镜盒
Lucia: My glasses case.
Katrina:  哎这个水是没开的吧
Katrina: Hey, this water hasn't been opened, right?
Lucia: 没开的那我可以开一瓶吗
Lucia: Not opened, can I open a bottle?
Lucia: 啊这瓶开过了
Lucia: Ah, this one's been opened.
Jake: 有点渴
Jake: Feeling a bit thirsty.
Lucia: 这瓶好像没开
Lucia: This one seems unopened.
Jake:这瓶没开
Lucia: 这瓶没开
Jake: 要不贴个名字吧
Jake: Why not label it?
Jake: 有那个小贴纸
Jake: There are small stickers.
Tasha:  有道理
Jake:还在吗
Jake: 嗯找不着了
Jake: Hmm, can't find them.
Alice: 这好好看
Alice: This looks nice.
Alice: 你可以在这折个角
Alice: You can fold a corner here.
Lucia: 有道理
Lucia: 但是如果大家都折了一个角的话
Alice: 不一样的角
Alice: Different corners.
Jake: OK那那能记住哈
Jake: OK, remember that.
Alice: 过来有个人是一个撕掉
Jake: Over here there's a slope.
Shure:  我回宿舍
Jake: Write it down.
Lucia: 我把外面就撕下来
Lucia:  给他叠个花
Jake: 就在这写个肩吧
Jake: Just write "shoulder" here.
Lucia: 找不到哦
Jake: 你还要画哦
Jake: You still need to draw it.
Lucia: 笔在这里
Lucia: 我先简单在这个白的地方画一道
Lucia: I'll first draw a line on this white part.
Alice:画一道好吧
Katrina:  你们毕设这么早吗
Katrina: Are you doing your final project this early?
Shure:  我们还有个模拟答辩
Shure: We still have a mock defense.
Shure:  很奇怪啊
Shure: It's strange.
Lucia: 你们还有模拟答辩
Lucia: You still have a mock defense?
Katrina:  论文还没写
Katrina: Haven't written the thesis yet.
Shure:  哦你是软件工程的是吧
Shure: Oh, you're in software engineering, right?
Katrina: 嗯
Shure:  好
Shure:  帮我改改代码吧
Shure: Help me debug my code.
Shure:  到时候哈哈哈
Shure: When the time comes, hahaha.
Katrina:  帮你改代码
Katrina: Help you debug your code?
Katrina:  我自己代码还没跑完呢
Katrina: I haven't even finished running my own code.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Shure:  太爽了
Shure: This is awesome.
Shure:  出去搞杯咖啡喝
Shure: Let's go get a coffee.
Shure:  在外面坐一坐晒晒太阳
Shure: Sit outside and enjoy the sun.
Shure:  无敌了
Shure: Unbeatable.
Jake: 点外卖吗
Jake: Order takeout?
Tasha: 吃午饭吗吃午饭吗
Lucia: 对一点不饿
Lucia: No, not hungry at all.
Jake: 一点不饿是吧
Jake: Not hungry at all?
Jake: 对我们再录40分钟就结束了这一轮
Jake: Right, we'll finish this round in 40 more minutes.
Jake: 然后40分钟能干嘛呢
Jake: So what can we do in 40 minutes?
Jake: 点个外卖
Jake: Let's order takeout.
Jake: 就是有40分钟外卖差不多能到吧
Jake: The takeout should arrive in about 40 minutes, right?
Jake: 对吧可以现在点一下
Jake: Right? We can order now.
Jake: 然后大概准备一下下午买点啥
Jake: Then let's prepare a bit for what to buy in the afternoon.
Jake: 在这写一写
Jake: Write it down here.
Jake: 拉倒了做东西
Jake: Forget it, let's make something.
Tasha: 就是在一楼做是吗
Tasha: We're doing it on the first floor, right?
Jake: 在一楼做
Jake: On the first floor.
Tasha: 哦我就是问问
Jake: 对在一楼做
Jake: Yes, on the first floor.
Jake: 然后在这摆这个
Jake: And then set this up here.
Jake: 这个就当就是工作台
Jake: This will be like a workbench.
Lucia: 工作台工作台
Lucia: Workbench, workbench.
Jake: 和甜点的那个台子放在也是这边是吧
Jake: And the dessert table will also be here, right?
Tasha: 好
Shure:  不是就是他
Shure: No, I mean he...
Shure:  是对是
Shure: Yes, he is.
Jake: 这就是一个厨房
Jake: This is the kitchen.
Jake:全是你的
Tasha: 谢谢
Alice: 开放的
Jake:对上面是活动室
Tasha: It's open. If it is, then upstairs is the activity room.
Jake: 这边是会议室和厨房合理吧
Jake: This area is the meeting room and kitchen, right?
Shure:  我也带稍微带一点
Shure: I will bring a bit too.
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: 把所有的模具都放到这个袋子里
Tasha: Put all the molds into this bag.
Shure:  开飞机就要很大的钱
Shure: Flying a plane costs a lot of money.
Lucia: 这个哦哦这是
Lucia: This, oh, this is...
Lucia: 这是某位同学的眼镜
Lucia: These are someone's glasses.
Lucia: 我还以为是我们戴的这个太像了
Shure:  混淆你们用的
Shure: Confused with yours.
Jake: 我这个擦掉了
Jake: I wiped this off.
Jake: 你们想写就写
Jake: Write if you want to.
Lucia: 眼镜中混入了一个叛徒
Lucia: There’s a traitor among the glasses.
Shure:  AI中混入了一个傻子哈哈哈
Lucia: 哎这个白板没有背面吗
Lucia: Hey, doesn't this whiteboard have a back?
Lucia: 只有一面有背面
Lucia: Only one side has a back?
Jake: 背面是个黑板啊OK
Jake: The back is a blackboard, OK.
Lucia: 啊OK
Jake: 对可以用粉笔写啊
Jake: Yes, you can write with chalk.
Jake: 他还给粉笔
Lucia: 原来是这样的设计
Lucia: So that's the design.
Lucia: 对这个是这备用的一套是吗
Lucia: Is this an extra set?
Lucia: 没有是吧
Lucia: No, right?
Lucia: 就是那个
Lucia: Just that one.
Lucia: 这个刀拿开是吗
Lucia: Move the knife away, right?
Tasha: 我靠
Lucia: 啊小心手
Lucia: 这个挺利的
Lucia: This is pretty sharp.
Lucia: 我们家好像拿这个打过
Lucia: I think my family used this to make juice.
Lucia: 果汁之类的东西
Lucia: Like fruit juice and stuff.
Jake: 要不整点咖啡
Jake: How about we make some coffee?
Jake: 咖啡整很好了是吧
Jake: The coffee is ready, right?
Shure:  啊
Jake: 咖啡整好了
Shure: 咖啡好像没有那么多
Jake: 哦哦
Shure: 而且只只能手冲
Jake: 那每人喝一口吧
Jake: Everyone just take a sip.
Jake: 哈哈哈一小杯就是one shot的啊
Jake: Hahaha, just a small cup to taste.
Shure:  OKone shot咖啡
Shure:  咖啡也按shot喝是吧
Jake:对对对
Shure:  直接shot浓缩
Lucia: 哈哈对我我刚开始点是不会点
Shure: Haha, yeah, I didn't know how to order at first.
Lucia: 真的点过一 shot
Lucia: I really ordered a concentrated shot.
Lucia: 浓缩上来的时候我都惊呆了
Lucia: When the espresso came, I was stunned.
Lucia: 啊这是点咖啡
Tasha: 嗯
Lucia: 我刚开始不会点
Lucia: I didn't know how to order at first.
Lucia: 然后就是点过那种纯的espresso就一shot
Lucia: So I ordered a pure espresso shot.
Lucia: 然后上来我真的惊呆了
Lucia: When it came, I was really stunned.
Lucia: 这怎么喝
Lucia: How do you drink this?
Lucia: 哈哈是好
Lucia: Haha, it's good.
Shure:  我们现在开始中午饭
Shure: Now let's start lunch.
Jake: 午饭点外卖
Jake: Let's order takeout.
Jake: 外卖点什么呢
Jake: What should we order?
Jake: 看一看
Shure:  吃的点什么
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 美团外卖
Shure: 美团外卖送啥都快
Lucia: 呃那个是干嘛的呀
Lucia: Uh, what is that for?
Lucia: 就是就是用来放它的吗
Lucia: Is it just to place it there?
Tasha:  嗯对
Alice:要不然它会跑
Lucia: 哦OK
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: 他是用来干嘛的
Alice: 做他的lunch
Jake:打空气
Jake:要不
Katrina: 我记一下我要买啥
Jake: 报个菜名
Jake: Name a dish.
Jake: 吃我请您吃
Jake: I'll treat you.
Shure:  我请大家吃
Shure: I'll treat everyone.
Shure:  何帆不认识饭
Shure: Hefan doesn't know rice.
Shure:  牛肉饭加锅炉
Shure: Beef rice with a boiler.
Shure:  小锅牛肉吉野家
Shure: Small pot beef Yoshinoya.
Shure:  肯德基宅基送聚德
Shure: KFC delivery, Jide.
Shure:  上北京烤鸭老街春饼
Shure: Peking duck, Laojie spring pancake.
Shure:  南城香饭香串香馄饨香
Shure: Nanchengxiang rice, fragrant skewers, fragrant wontons.
Shure:  小栋酿猪脚饭
Shure: Xiaodong braised pig's foot rice.
Shure:  酱骨饭汉堡王本味龙江猪脚饭
Shure: Braised bone rice, Burger King, Benwei Longjiang pig's foot rice.
Shure:  人民公社大食堂神话烤鱼
Shure: People's Commune cafeteria, Myth grilled fish.
Shure:  便益坊烤鸭河间驴肉火烧
Shure: Bianyifang roast duck, Hejian donkey meat sandwich.
Shure:  河谷烧
Shure: Hegu roast.
Shure:  日料寿司田老师红烧肉张记京味卤煮
Shure: Japanese cuisine sushi, Mr. Tian's braised pork, Zhang Ji Beijing-style stewed dishes.
Jake: 哈哈哈吃啥
Shure:  他们肯定一个都没记住
Shure: They probably didn't remember any of it.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Jake:自己都没记住
Lucia: 我就听到一个KFC
Jake: 好那就KFC吧怎么样
Jake: Alright, let's go with KFC then, how about it?
Lucia: 不不不我只是只记得这个
Jake: 因为太快了
Jake: Because it was too fast.
Shure: 汉堡王啊
Jake: 汉堡可以就就肯德基
Jake: Burgers, okay, just KFC.
Jake: 就KFC给外国人一些小震撼
Jake: Just KFC, give foreigners a little shock.
Lucia: 我我没有忌口
Lucia: 所以大家吃什么都行
Lucia: So, I'm okay with whatever everyone eats.
Lucia: 我都可以flow
Katrina: 我想吃那奥尔良
Jake: 好那就
xiaowei :把厨具我们都拆一下嘛
Shure:  KFC全家桶
Jake:KFC
Jake: 呃有些新品
Jake: Uh, some new items
Jake: 热辣不羁全是肉
Jake: Spicy and wild, all meat
Jake: 尊享无敌披萨
Jake: Premium unbeatable pizza
Alice: 用之前记得刷一遍披萨
Alice: Remember to brush the pizza once before using
Tasha: 等一会豆洗一下吧
Jake: 下面全是肉的披萨
Jake: Pizza with all meat underneath
Tasha: 这个就可以放这里面
Tasha: 和那个点动打蛋器
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 要是没裹上我就先把这个再拔下来了
Jake: I'll take this off since the clothes didn't cover it
Lucia: 这样我就可以自由活动
Lucia: Now I can move freely
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay
Lucia: 反正这里面电应该还够
Tasha: 这个放烤箱里
Tasha: Put this in the oven
Jake: 这烤箱是不是有点歪
Jake: Is this oven a bit crooked?
Jake: 放这里面吗
Jake: Put it in here?
Tasha: 你那其实把它放上面也可以
Tasha: Actually, you can put it on top too
Jake: 好的
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh
Lucia: 需要把要洗的东西单独挑出来一下吗
Lucia: Should we separate the items that need to be washed?
Jake: 好啊啊你们
Jake: Alright, you guys
Tasha: 好的对那这个先不给路亚选
Tasha: Okay, then let's not choose this for Luya
Jake: 哦这个底下哈哈哈
Jake: Oh, this bottom part haha
Tasha: 啊什么
Tasha: What?
Jake: 路亚一般不会第一个选是吧
Jake: Luya usually doesn't pick first, right?
Jake: 哦对我一般都follow
Jake: Oh yeah, I usually follow
Lucia: 就是大家选过的选项
Lucia: Just after everyone else chooses
Lucia: 就是点菜的时候好那个眼镜把
Lucia: When ordering food, okay, those glasses
Tasha: 好我们把那边先清理一下
Jake: 先点吧要不
Jake: Let's order first, maybe
Alice: 哎呀
Alice: Oh dear
Tasha: 这whowho是眼镜
Tasha: Camouflage glasses.
Lucia: 这个是不是也要拆一下
Lucia: Should we take this apart too?
Lucia: 就是撒糖霜的那个是吧
Lucia: Is this the one for sprinkling powdered sugar?
Shure:  老板你你吃鸡堡
Shure: Boss, are you eating the chicken burger?
Shure:  吃牛堡哎
Shure: Or the beef burger?
Jake: 我能吃那个披萨吗
Jake: Can I eat that pizza?
Shure:  可以
Lucia: 这有垃圾桶
Shure:  有人吃鸡堡吗
Tasha: 好我不想吃堡
Jake: 好那你可以吃什么
Jake: 那你想吃什么
Jake: So what do you want to eat?
Jake: 你不想吃肯德基是吧
Jake: You don't want to eat KFC, right?
Tasha: 不是不是我不想吃汉堡
Tasha: No, no, I don't want to eat a burger.
Tasha: 哦哦哦鸡肉卷
Tasha: Oh, oh, a chicken wrap.
Alice: 要帮你吗
Shure:  一个2两的
Shure: A 2-ounce one.
Shure:  然后一个
Shure: And then a...
Tasha: 好好
Jake:你帮我推进去
Shure: Okay, help me push it in.
Jake: 我把这个弄起来
Jake: I'll lift this up.
Shure:  好OK
Shure: Alright, okay.
Lucia: 这个袋子要拆掉吗
Lucia: Should we take this bag apart?
Tasha: 都要拆的
Tasha: We need to take all of them apart.
Jake: 走走一波
Tasha: 呃我先把线扯掉
Jake:把线洗一洗
Tasha: 怎么回事
Tasha: 这其实还可以烤烤鸡来着
Tasha: Actually, you can roast chicken with this too.
Jake: 妙妙
Jake: Wonderful.
Tasha: 行了就这样把
Tasha: 这线插哪
Tasha: Done
Tasha: 这这些都是材
Tasha: These are all materials
Tasha: 食材就行啊
Tasha: Just need ingredients.
Tasha: 把粉的放一起
Tasha: Put the powder ones together.
Tasha: 食材放一起
Tasha: Put all the ingredients together.
Lucia: OK OK
Tasha: 好嗯
Tasha: Alright.
Lucia: 这些也都要拆掉了是吧
Tasha: 对
Lucia: 这都是粉
Lucia: This is all powder.
Tasha: 粉放到哪里呢
Tasha: Where should we put the powder?
Tasha: 粉就放这吧
Tasha: Let's just put it here.
Jake: 点完了
Jake: Done ordering.
Jake: 点了几个
Jake: How many did you order?
Shure:  点了个双人餐
Shure: Ordered a meal for two.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure:  对那是我
Shure: Yeah, that was me.
Shure:  我点了一个双人餐
Shure: I ordered a meal for two.
Jake: 你一个人点了个双人餐
Jake: You ordered a meal for two by yourself?
Jake: 不是我我和那个
Jake: No, me and...
Katrina: 雨轩
Shure:  雨轩对
Shure: Yuxuan, right.
Jake: 好吃什么呢
Tasha: 电池呢
Jake:吃电池
Tasha: 我刚刚放桌上
Lucia: 要不放冰箱
Tasha: 哦我找着了
Tasha: Oh, I found it.
Shure:  辛苦你帮我通知一下
Shure: Thanks for letting me know.
Jake: 找着电池了是吧
Jake: Found the battery, right?
Tasha: 因为这个电池是我带来的
Lucia:  这个里面本来就有放东西
Jake:等一下啊
Lucia: 应该可以放吸奶油什么的
Lucia: It should be able to hold whipped cream and stuff.
Tasha: 还有套餐吗哈哈
Tasha: Is there a meal set left? Haha.
Jake:搜一搜
Jake: 没有哎有是是这个吗
Jake: No, wait, is this it?
Tasha: 那这不就一个吗
Tasha: Isn't this just one?
Tasha: 那就没有了
Tasha: Then there's none left.
Tasha: 那好吧那还是这个吧
Tasha: Okay then. Jake: Let's stick with this one.
Jake: 不用套餐单点一些喝的是吗
Tasha: 好的
Tasha: 喝的不用了吧就好没了
Tasha: No drinks, that's fine.
Jake:好没了
Jake: 嗯还有吗
Jake: Hmm, anything else?
Tasha:  没了
Jake: 别的呢
Jake: 这些小东西
Jake: These little things.
Tasha: 那我跟着他们吃吧
Tasha: I'll just eat with them.
Tasha: 这也是会点套餐吧
Tasha: This could also be a set meal, right?
Lucia: 巧克力是不是有两包
Lucia: Aren't there two packs of chocolate?
Tasha: 不是一个是可可粉一个是可可豆
Jake:来点
Alice: 哇都点好了吗
Alice: Wow, have you finished ordering?
Jake: 她点了三个
Lucia: 呵呵但是被阳光晒的话他会不会坏
Lucia: Hehe, but will it spoil if exposed to sunlight?
Katrina:  哦
Katrina: Oh.
Lucia: 那我们要不然就放在放在这边
Tasha: 啊粉类可以放
Tasha: 粉类可以放在这里没关系
Lucia: 这个地方不是很容易晒到
Alice:粉类巧克力我都搁那个那里边
Tasha: 巧克力
Alice:给我吧
Tasha: 巧克力可以放冰箱
Tasha: Chocolate can go in the fridge.
Jake: 给你一个
Jake: Here, one for you.
Lucia: 这个是放在外面还是要放到冰箱去
Lucia: Should this be kept outside or put in the fridge?
Tasha: 这个放常温就行
Jake: 你要喝的吗
Jake: Want something to drink?
Tasha: 不知道放哪
Jake: Coffee liqueur?
Tasha: 咖啡就放冰箱
Lucia: 好的
Tasha: 要不这也放冰箱吧
Tasha: Or this too, put it in the fridge.
Tasha: 没地方放
Tasha: No space.
Lucia: 行反正冰箱里东西少空间多
Lucia: Fine, there's not much in the fridge anyway, plenty of space.
Tasha: 这个硅油纸谁把它放进去的
Tasha: Who put this parchment paper in here?
Tasha: 这个稍微往边上挪一点好
Tasha: Just move it a bit to the side, okay?
Jake: 来吧到你了
Jake: Come on, it's your turn.
Lucia: 让我看看大家都点了什么
Lucia: Let me see what everyone ordered.
Tasha: 真嘟放不下了
Tasha: Really can't fit anymore.
Lucia: 哎让我参考一下
Lucia: Hey, let me take a look.
Alice: 还有一个托盘
Alice: There's another tray.
Tasha: 哎这其实还有个托盘
Tasha: Hey, there's actually another tray.
Tasha: 那那要不把这这个给挪开
Tasha: Well, how about we move this aside?
Tasha: 把那个水壶也给挪开
Tasha: Move the kettle too.
Tasha: 这边就放点小的对
Shure: 这是什么啊小甜水
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: 那把这个放那吧
Jake:路亚是J人P人
Lucia: 万不得已
Jake:塔莎
Jake:是J
Tasha: 我是P人
Jake:P 人J人
Alice:你觉得呢
Jake:很J人
Alice:我是P
Jake:唯一的
Katrina: 唯一的J人吗
Jake:这个地方你的了给你划一个区
Jake:J区
Katrina: 时间地点然后需要什么材料
Jake:J区P区
Alice:这个给它搁哪
Tasha: 这个是备用的刀片
Tasha: This is the spare blade.
Tasha: 然后不用搁哪
Tasha: And then we don't need to put it anywhere.
Tasha: 这个也是
Alice:搁这吧
Tasha: 我感觉这个没这个好使
Tasha: I feel like this one isn't as good.
Alice: 那就给他搁这吧
Alice: Then let's just leave it here.
Tasha: 嗯行
Jake: 这个能晒吗
Jake: Can this be dried in the sun?
Jake: 这些东西
Jake: These things?
Tasha: 可以粉没事
Jake: 对粉都晒的
Shure:  不都阴暗避光保存吗
Jake: 还有电
Tasha: 玉米油
Jake: 行
Jake: Okay.
Alice:哎你放那挡着
Alice: 你拿那些就搁
Jake:乱走的P人
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure:  我们在我们在观摩J人
Lucia: 哎肯德基现在居然还有牛肉汉堡了
Lucia: Hey, KFC now actually has beef burgers.
Shure:  他俩应该配料都差不多
Shure: They probably have similar ingredients.
Tasha: 到时候就在这裱花吧
Tasha: We'll do the icing here then.
Shure:  对你这这些东西我都拿伏特加对过
Shure: Yeah, I've mixed all these things with vodka.
Shure:  都基本是一块
Shure: They basically taste the same.
Jake: 我先把这个填起来
Jake: I'll fill this up first.
Shure:  哎呀哎哎呀哎呀
Shure: Oh dear, oh dear, oh dear.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake: 真是多才多艺
Lucia: 这是怎么发出的声音
Jake: 12个12个现在
Jake: 12 of them now.
Shure:  差不多就行
Shure: That's about right.
Jake: 环保环保
Jake: Eco-friendly, eco-friendly.
Jake: 环啊环保
Jake: Yeah, eco-friendly.
Shure:  不能是吧
Shure: Can't be, right?
Shure:  啊那那不行
Shure: Ah, that's not gonna work.
Shure:  纸杯也就不行了
Shure: The paper cups won't work either.
Lucia:  我好了好的
Jake:好的
Lucia: 谢谢
Shure:  杯子就再说
Shure: We'll talk about the cups later.
Shure:  先不用买了
Shure: No need to buy them for now.
Jake: 我们点了
Shure: 点吧
Shure:  觉得差不多
Shure: Seems about right.
Jake: 我们总共三个
Jake: We have a total of three.
Jake: 可乐
Shure:  我一会要coffee
Shure: I need coffee later.
Shure:  coffee没有coffee会死的
Shure: Can't live without coffee.
Jake: 我们要哎
Jake: We need to...
Jake: 肯德基是不是不用餐具点俩吧
Jake: Should we order utensils from KFC?
Lucia: 呃咱们早上有剩下的餐具
Lucia: Uh, we have some leftover utensils from the morning.
Jake:哦那就点3个
Jake: 因为剩下的三个是吧
Tasha: 什么东西
Lucia: 哎不记得剩下几个啊
Lucia: Oh, I don't remember how many are left.
Alice: 餐具
Tasha: 哦哎等一下
Alice: 动作太大
Alice: Too much movement.
Jake: 好滴点了
Jake: Alright, ordered.
Jake: 大家等饭吃吧
Jake: Let's wait for the food, everyone.
Lucia: 我们我们要调几种酒啊
Lucia: How many kinds of liquor are we mixing?
Lucia: 基酒的话
Lucia: 威士忌和龙舌兰也可以考虑一下
Lucia: We could consider whiskey and tequila.
Shure:  没事我
Lucia: 我投龙舌兰日出一票哈哈
Shure: No worries, I'll vote for a sunrise cocktail tomorrow, haha.
Katrina: 你有这个那就买一瓶朗姆就行了
Shure:  我明天回宿舍看看有什么拿点
Shure: I'll check my dorm tomorrow and bring some if I find any.
Katrina: 我们是应该是会有多次采购吧
Jake: 对是的
Jake: Yes, that's right.
Lucia: 如果买了老母的话不买龙舌兰
Lucia: If we buy rum, we don't need tequila.
Lucia: 爱心
Lucia: Love it.
Lucia: 我觉得风味还是有一点相似之处的
Lucia: I think the flavors are somewhat similar.
Jake: 大概去个两次吧应该
Jake: We should probably go twice, I guess.
Jake: 多的话就只能靠剧组带了
Jake: If there's too much, we'll have to rely on the crew to bring it.
Tasha: 剧组今天怎么不来
Tasha: Why isn't the crew coming today?
Jake:剧组上课去了
Jake:剧组很忙
Jake:剧组兼职剧组
Tasha: 把厨具洗一下吧
Jake:好嘞
Tasha: 清水冲就行
Tasha: 我觉得要冲的就只有
Tasha: 呃这里面的都要冲
Tasha: and这一套
Jake:好
Jake:就过水
Tasha: 啊对还有这些烤盘
Jake:哦这些洗一洗
Jake:这个要怎么洗
Tasha: 这个其实冲一下就行因为也会铺油纸
Jake:哦
Shure:  行d万能的
Shure: Alright, it's all good.
Shure:  啊西柚味那个
Shure:  这些喝不了
Shure: We can't drink these.
Shure:  就当随时的饮料用
Shure: Just use them as backup drinks.
Alice: 需要洗吗
Alice: Do they need to be washed?
Tasha: 他说他洗啊洗
Tasha: He said wash them, yeah, wash them.
Tasha:  哈哈
Jake: 对对对
Tasha: 休息一下
Tasha: Take a break.
Tasha: 你已经整理过很多东西了
Tasha: You've already organized a lot of stuff.
Alice: 没关系是的
Jake: 休息一下
Jake: Take a break.
Jake: 拼命图休息一下
Jake: Take a break from the hustle.
Jake: 打散了再拼一次
Jake: 拼拼图
Alice:算了算了
Alice: 我不想看见他了
Jake: 休息一下
Jake: Take a break.
Jake: 或者你们上楼或者转一转
Jake: Or you can go upstairs or take a walk.
Shure:  装完所有零件
Shure: Install all the parts.
Jake:就是一起帮他填片白板吧
Shure: Just help him fill the whiteboard.
Shure: 我把那个笔记本拆了清灰然后全拆完
Shure:  最后都装回去
Shure: Put everything back together.
Jake:帮我把这些东西都给扔出去吧
Jake: 要不就是没用的东西都给扔出去
Jake: Or just throw out all the useless stuff.
Jake: 对就是这个
Jake: Yes, exactly that.
Jake: 然后他们采购的东西补一补
Jake: Then we can restock what they purchased.
Lucia: 对但是其实也不一定非要放这么多
Lucia: Yes, but we don't necessarily need to put so much.
Lucia: 就是朗姆酒加椰汁兑
Lucia: It's just rum mixed with coconut milk.
Lucia: 然后我个人觉得可能就菠萝汁
Lucia: Personally, I think maybe pineapple juice.
Lucia: 换成别的果汁也行
Lucia: You can substitute other juices too.
Lucia: 因为咱也不需要调的那么正经嘛对吧
Lucia: We don't need to be so formal with the mixing, right?
Lucia: 所以可以考虑一下
Lucia: So we can consider it.
Katrina: 喝着玩吧
Tasha: 嗨
Alice:你做甜品的时候可以帮你
Tasha: 好啊是一个超级的
Tasha: Sure, that would be awesome.
Jake: 我们还有20分钟就结束了这一段
Jake: We have 20 minutes left to finish this part.
Jake: 然后20分钟之内
Jake: And within 20 minutes,
Jake: 呃就就把这些事情都给截掉
Jake: uh, just cut all these things.
Jake: 然后是一个完整的片段
Jake: Then it’ll be a complete segment.
Shure:  好吧好那我们就这个片段
Shure: Alright, we'll do that segment then.
Shure:  就是5个P人观察一个J人的计划
YLB :对就是我们现在就收尾
Shure: Yeah, we're wrapping it up now.
Jake: 就不要开新的事情了就把这个给收掉
Jake: 稳
Lucia: 那我们就大家围在一起观察一下吧
Katrina: 差不多吧
Tasha: 帮我写一下
Tasha: Help me write it down.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 鸡蛋
Jake: 你们要不做啊
Shure:  鸡蛋每天早上咱们可以煮着吃无菌蛋
Shure: We can boil sterilized eggs every morning.
Tasha: 鸡蛋
Lucia: 每天早上煮
Tasha: 嗯白糖是不是也没有
Alice: 有糖粉但是没白糖
Alice: We have powdered sugar but no white sugar.
Tasha: 可是我觉得白糖其实呃好一些
Alice: But I think white sugar is actually better.
Tasha: 嗯买吧白糖还有盐也需要一小包
Tasha: Hmm, let's buy some. We also need a small pack of salt.
Tasha: 你可以写在一起
Tasha: Can you write it down together?
Katrina: 要不要一次性餐具
Tasha: Do we need disposable utensils?
Shure: 不环保
Tasha: 盐一次性餐具打算从网上买
Katrina: 不环保他们拿啥吃呢
Shure:  手抓哈哈哈
Shure: Just grab it with your hands, haha.
Katrina: 手抓
Shure:  烤出来直接拿那个夹子啪放手上
Katrina: 白糖盐
Tasha: 嗯等一下我从第一个开始看牛奶
Tasha: Hmm, wait a second, let me check the milk first.
Shure:  还有个雪克锅的
Tasha: 淡奶油
Shure:  晚上整一个寿喜锅吃
Shure: Let's make sukiyaki for dinner.
Katrina: 奶油可以单买
Alice: 鸡蛋用无菌蛋吧
Alice: Let's use sterilized eggs.
Tasha: 对用无菌蛋也更好一些了
Tasha: Yeah, using sterilized eggs is better.
Shure:  那还可以生吃
Shure: Then we can eat them raw too.
Shure:  每天早上
Shure: Every morning.
Tasha: 呃鸡蛋汤
Tasha: Uh, egg soup.
Tasha: 嗯也可以买点装饰薄荷什么
Tasha: Hmm, we can also buy some mint for decoration or something.
Tasha: 调酒是不是也可以用
Tasha: Can we use it for cocktails too?
Katrina: 对
Tasha: 薄荷百里香什么都可以
Tasha: Mint, thyme, we can use them all.
Tasha: 保鲜膜保鲜膜
Tasha: Cling film, cling film.
Tasha: 这有吗
Jake:没有
Jake: 呃我没看到应该没有吧
Jake: Uh, I didn't see it, there shouldn't be any, right?
Jake: 路亚看过没有对吧
Jake: Have you seen the lure? No, right?
Lucia: 没有应该是没有
Lucia: No, I don't think so.
Jake:应该没有
Lucia: 好的他们这餐具只有
Lucia: Okay, they only have utensils like
Lucia: 比如说那个锅碗瓢盆这些
Lucia: things like pots and pans.
Tasha: 牛奶淡奶油
Tasha: 鸡蛋淀粉嗯盐盐液小糖牛奶淡奶油
Tasha: Eggs, starch, hmm, salt, saline, a bit of sugar, milk, heavy cream.
Tasha: 如果有一小包的奶粉也可以带一包
Tasha: If there's a small packet of milk powder, you can bring that too.
Tasha: 一一包奶粉
Tasha: Salt, a packet of milk powder.
Tasha: 咖啡粉咖啡粉手冲吧
Tasha: Coffee powder, let's do hand-brewed coffee.
Shure:  跟那个不一样吧
Shure: Isn't that different?
Shure:  你要的是什么咖啡
Shure: What kind of coffee do you want?
Tasha: 我就要一包咖啡粉
Shure: I just want a packet of coffee powder.
Katrina: 做提拉米苏吗
Tasha: 啊对
Lucia: 喝的用的咖啡粉也可以吗
Tasha: 对
Tasha: 啊你们不磨吗
Tasha: Ah, don't you grind it?
Katrina: 啊我也想买点咖啡条喝万一嘛
Tasha: Ah, I also want to buy some coffee for drinking, just in case.
Jake: 哎我我还带了一个咖鸭
Jake: Hey, I also brought a coffee duck.
Jake: 就是新加坡的一个很很奇怪的调料
Jake: It's a very strange condiment from Singapore.
Tasha: 也可以再写蛋挞皮
Alice: 这个纸箱还要吗
Alice: Do we still need this cardboard box?
Lucia: 这纸箱要不要留一下
Lucia: Should we keep this cardboard box?
Jake:留着留着
Lucia: 假如我们要做一些什么纸箱
Lucia: 狗之类的可以摆在门口
Lucia: Like a dog or something, to put at the door.
Lucia: 然后就当迎宾
Lucia: And use it as a greeter.
Katrina: 蛋挞的挞怎么写
Jake: 对纸箱留着吧
Jake: Yeah, keep the cardboard boxes.
Jake: 放在外面那种
Jake: Put them outside.
Lucia: 那种特别软特别薄的就不需要了
Shure: 帮我加一个咖啡豆
Lucia: 或者说就是破破损面积很大
Tasha:那加咖啡豆就不用咖啡粉了
Katrina: 咖啡豆确定还没到
Katrina: 那咖啡豆用什么磨呀
Shure:  我明天我明天补给一波装备
Shure:  我今天回家啊我回宿舍补给
Shure: I'm heading home today, back to the dorm for supplies.
Tasha: 然后再买草莓
Tasha: And then buy some strawberries.
Shure:  想想啊有音箱话筒然后咖啡
Tasha: 草莓
Shure: 草莓能放几天啊
Tasha: 草莓能放
Tasha: Strawberries can last...
Tasha: 放冰箱的话两三天吧
Tasha: If you put them in the fridge, two or three days.
Shure:  3天吧
Shure: About 3 days.
Jake: 3天我们不会吃吗
Jake: Wouldn't we eat them in 3 days?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 那就大概过上三四天左右再去
Lucia: So, we can go buy more in three or four days.
Lucia: 买一次对
Lucia: Once, right?
Tasha: 然后就没有了
Shure:  不咖啡豆没了
Shure:  我需要买
Shure: I need to buy some.
Shure:  趁机补给一波
Shure:  咖啡的一些东西
Shure:  嗯以及泡咖啡
Shure: And some coffee brewing supplies.
Lucia: 这个手套要不
Lucia: Should we put this glove...
Lucia: 放这好了
Lucia: Here?
Jake: 对我们这边只有一个j
Jake: Yeah, we only have one "J" here.
Jake: 然后没有s
Jake: And no "S".
Lucia: 竟然没有s
Lucia: There's no "S"?
Jake:没有s
Lucia: No "S"?
Jake: 是我们总共30多个报名的人里边
Jake: Out of the 30 people who signed up,
Jake: 就三
Jake:就两个s
Tasha: S S是啥
Alice: s觉得这种事没有意义
Alice: "S" feels like it's pointless.
Lucia: 有可能s比较
Lucia: Maybe "S" is more...
Jake: s是是啥好像是
Jake: "S" is... like...
Jake: 什么感性和直觉和感觉
Jake: something intuitive and feeling-based.
Lucia: 直觉和感觉
Lucia: Intuition and feelings.
Jake: 对实感
Jake: Yeah, and real sensation.
Jake: 就这个实在是没法打官司
Jake: This really can't be litigated.
Lucia:  原来如此
Jake: Hahaha, I see.
Lucia: 那所以是p人更多还是j人更多
Lucia: So are there more P people or J people?
Lucia: 按照按照就是最终的结果来说的话
Lucia: According to the final results...
Lucia: 应该报名的时候也是p人多
Lucia: There should be more P people signing up.
Jake:对对对压倒性的
Tasha:  p人多
Tasha: 为什么p人多
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh...
Lucia: 这个可以扔了吗
Lucia: Can this be thrown away?
Lucia: 这里面还有一个
Lucia: There's still one inside.
Lucia: 这个也
Lucia: This one too...
Lucia: 应该也是裱花嘴的时候要扔了啊
Lucia: Should be thrown away after using the piping tip, right?
Tasha: 对这是转换器
Tasha: Yes, it's a converter.
Lucia: 那这个放在跟那些放一起吧
Lucia: So let's put this together with those.
Lucia: 然后这个可以扔了对吧
Lucia: And then throw this away, right?
Tasha: 对
Lucia: 那就扔掉了
Jake: 就是第一波那个
Jake: It's like the first wave...
Jake: 呃复活节的那一次
Jake: Uh, during Easter.
Jake: 呃那报名的里边只有三个
Jake: Uh, there were only three in the registrations.
Jake: 只有三种
Jake: Only three types.
Jake: 只有只有三种
Jake: Only, only three types.
Jake: 这个NBTI只有三种
Jake: This NBTI only had three types.
Jake: 对总共十几个人总共我们把那个把这个喝了吧
Jake: Yeah, out of a total of about ten people.
Shure:  美汁源喝了吧
Shure: Let's drink it.
Lucia: 幸好最后我没有复活
Lucia: Luckily, I didn't revive in the end.
Lucia:节举办因为突然
Lucia: The ending was sudden because...
Lucia: 就是就是突然之间
Lucia: It was just all of a sudden...
Lucia: 我就是那一周事情还蛮多的
Lucia: I had a lot going on that week.
Lucia: 然后我一直忙到就是来这之前的一周
Lucia: And I was busy until the week before coming here.
Katrina: 哇好专业呀
Lucia: 所以还是机缘巧合的
Shure: Hey, there's a piece here, it's a coincidence.
Lucia: 很荣幸认识大家
Lucia: It's an honor to meet everyone.
Alice: 对要做那啥的啊
Alice: Yeah, we need to do that thing
Tasha: 哈哈这个不能动他
Tasha: Haha, you can't move it
Tasha: 这还可以煮火锅哎
Tasha: This can also be used for hotpot
Alice: 把这个也打了吧
Alice: Let's hit this one too
Jake: 搞一天火锅
Jake: Let's do hotpot for a day
Jake: 可以啊
Jake: Sure, we can do that
Lucia: 哎对火锅也比较方便
Lucia: Oh yeah, hotpot is pretty convenient
Lucia: 买一些简单的食材
Lucia: Just buy some simple ingredients
Tasha: 火锅底料
Lucia: 直接煮就好了
Tasha: 丸子羊肉片
Lucia: 对
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: Yeah, yeah
Lucia: 我们自己做饭的环节
Lucia: Our cooking session
Lucia: 不如就做火锅
Lucia: Why not just make hotpot
Alice: 这是我们买的
Alice: This is what we bought
Jake:可以
Shure:  他这冰箱全是空的
Shure: His fridge is completely empty